what's going on guys we are with a very
special guest today he is the
screenwriter of American ultra chronicle
he's an entrepreneur a dreamer thank you
for making time for us max landis thank
you so much you I feel like a dreamer
Renaissance man I feel like this is a
nice way of saying I'm a male prostitute
oh yeah I mean anything for money you
will - yeah anything you've done it um
welcome to being a screenwriter
you came on movie fights recently and
you blew the doors off movie fights you
are so someone say maybe too much I had
a little bit too much enthusiasm but I
had so much fun
haters gonna hate yeah it's true yeah so
um you had a lot of fun and you pitched
us an awesome dream sequel for Man of
Steel - do you want to give us any
preface for this what inspired it or
your thoughts your history with Superman
yeah I I've I've loved the character of
Superman since I was very little I've
talked about Superman way too much on
the Internet in public I have my blue
I'm literally living a dream right now
because on in November the first issue
of a 7 issue run called American alien
which is my Superman comic comes out and
it's really it's me putting my money
where my mouth is the thing the thing I
pitched was off the top of my head yes
and I feel like it ultimately addressed
a lot of things that might be looked at
in dawn of Justice and he told me like
Batman's in it and I was like my
Superman sequel in my head would never
include Batman mmm so I was like I guess
I gotta try to fit in everybody so I
hope you I hope you enjoy it I did enjoy
it let's take a look at it in the wake
of destruction of over half of
Metropolis at the end of Man of Steel
Superman is a universally reviled figure
Clark Kent a small-town boy who had
never even been in a fistfight before he
was attacked by a military man forced
the decimated City he loved has terrible
PTSD and has given up being Superman he
gets the shakes every night he's trying
to date Lois Lane but the fact that he
has a secret that she is doing a huge
piece on is being like very reviled
about the idea that Superman was
ultimately a negative thing
and that the destruction you know it's
911 it's ten 911s Clark moves home he is
miserable but he has to do one more
assignment before he leaves his job at
the Daily Planet and we get to really
see this guy I mean he's living in New
York post 9/11 basically everyone on the
street has graffiti saying like Superman
is credible she met sucks you know like
everyone also doesn't understand because
it's the age of the Internet that
Superman and Zod or even necessarily to
different people keep in mind the first
time the world saw that Superman suit
was in him destroying the city
so for all they know they were just two
random aliens in that haunts Clark every
night because he thinks of himself as a
man and as an American and is a good guy
and that tortures him he has to do one
more thing he has to go interview this
billionaire investor named Lex Luthor he
goes to interview him he doesn't
understand why he's been chosen he's a
rookie interviewer Lex Luthor is a shark
II investor he treats his employees like
it's basically an evil Elon Musk but
when he you're sitting there with him
and he's Tom Hanks he seems kind of
great
he's like Henry Cavill like you know you
and I have an image problem he's like
I'm just a reporter he goes you're not
you're Superman you think it was hard
for me to figure out who you were but I
think I can repair your image we're
gonna start branding you you are just
one man you'll never know where you're
needed and when but I am a corporation I
can send you where people need you most
I will have eyes and ears open for
people in need but I need you to do
favors for me I need you to repair
facilities around the world I think I
can make you look like the greatest
humanitarian figure of all time now is
that what you want to do do you want to
help people and inspire people with hope
he's like yes so it starts and suddenly
we're getting into all the stuff that we
didn't get to see in Man of Steel him
saving people him being sent places Lex
Luthor is sponsoring Superman it's
incredible he suddenly has a 60 Minutes
interview everyone starts to love
Superman like they do in the comics and
understand that what happened to
Metropolis was a mistake
that's when someone breaks into Clarke's
home it's a guy in a bat costume you
need to listen to me you can trust loser
or it's it's the water brothers maybe
something you listen what are you
talking about you've broken into my home
you're you're the Batman you're the
vigilante from Gotham that's right
listen it's part of a bigger plan he has
bad bad intentions but if you listen to
me I can help you out of this if you
work for me
instead of Luther as an agent of Batman
we can pull together the Earth's
greatest heroes we then enter the bulk
of the movie which is Luthor forcing
Superman to track down and capture the
members of the Justice League all the
other metahumans and they seem scary
the Flash's powers are out of control
Wonder Woman kills lots of people Green
Arrow is another friggin vigilante the
Martian Manhunter is a monster and by
the time you get to the third act he has
captured all of them and that's when
Luthor reveals what you've created is a
sovereign force more powerful than any
that has ever existed on earth this team
could take down any army no nation in
the world could stand against us and
Superman is like I thought we were doing
this to protect the world
I'm not even sweet he's like your next
job is to take out Batman and he's like
oh okay
so he goes to take out Batman because
Luthor is still sort of on his side even
though he's getting scarier and scarier
he still saved Clark Lex Luthor has
saved Superman from being a pariah and
as things grow in emotional intensity by
the end of the last act Superman with
Batman goes rogue because Bruce Wayne
basically says you didn't give away my
identity I know you know there's
something wrong with Luthor if you want
to inspire people do what I do inspire
by fear scare Luthor because that's what
he's making you do and Superman realizes
I don't need to beat life
I can't condemn him I can't testify on a
stand I can't say Who I am what I need
to do is free the Justice League so the
last act of the movie is Batman Superman
team-up they free the Justice League
have to fight Luthor and one of the
coolest sequences in movie history
beautifully beautifully directed by
James Cameron I'm pulling him off avatar
thank you the Justice League Justice
League
gets into a major fight in a city center
with Luthor's Luthor droids like the
robots except the whole time Superman
Clark is like they're hating Mac go save
those people we gotta send these people
so one member of the Justice League is
fighting the Luthor dreads at a time
there is almost no property damage and
no one is hurt and at the end of it
Superman lands and rips open the Luthor
Droid and Luthor's like you get hit kill
me on TV you know what are you doing you
destroy have a sit and then it's a slow
pan up and the city is fine I'm the
Justice League is like walking up behind
him and Luthor's like Oh Shh mr. Bennet
goes pink
knocks him out Justice League now exists
Man of Steel three I would want to focus
on doomsday Justice League versus Jim
say so max that was pretty epic anything
you change about that anything you want
to follow or note so many things I'd
change but I guess I guess if I could if
I could just choose one it would be to
make clear that I the actual sequel to
my Man of Steel 2 would be called
Superman and would be a movie where he I
say doomsday but to me that's the
Justice League movie and that comes out
later gotcha I think I think the sequel
in Superman I'd want him fighting
someone like Toyman like do a real
Superman movie yeah Clark is at work and
he has to done like also that'd be
pretty cool because we haven't seen
those characters on film before we
haven't even seen Brainiac
yeah if we've seen Zod twice and we
haven't seen Brainiac once the truth is
it's the most concise sparse uh least
nuanced characters that they use because
harder characters like mr. sinister he's
harder to pull off yeah and and you know
Brainiac
if you get up although it gives you an
opportunity to do the Marvel thing which
is an army of identical gray people
right how many you know you know why I
liked kingpin on daredevil why is that
cuz he wasn't a identical gray person I
love Marvel oh yeah have a villain who
can fight the whole team at once instead
of a million villains who can't beat the
whole team with a thousand of them one
of the things that interested me and I
really liked about your pitch was that
they were saving lives and they were
kind of cleaning up some of the the
damage from the first film why was that
important to you the Justice League is
Mount Olympus like in a literal way it's
Mount Olympus like if you look at the
the archetypes so I love the idea that
no matter who's coming at you once you
see that Green Dot in the sky and the
red blur in the streets and you hear the
sonic boom from Superman coming in here
the batwing overhead you see Wonder
Woman being taller than everybody yeah
the second you that happens you go oh
well I guess we're OK villains when
they're written right are terrifying yes
even the most minor comic book villain
in the real world would make it your
pants oh yeah and so the idea that no
there's a group of people who are going
to literally beat the crap out of
whoever made you feel scared and being
like oh thank god knowing that it was
going to be okay Wow and I wanted to
capture you know they don't really do
that in the last Avengers movie but I
wanted to capture that because the
Avengers are paramilitary unit that's
what they are the Justice League are not
a paramilitary unit right they're gods
any one member of the Justice League
of the like main seven could easily beat
the entirety of the Avengers
I didn't even Thor yeah Louie if Thor's
gonna stand a chance against Superman
okay he has a pure heart he's gonna pick
up that hammer he's won't you shove it
up Thor's ass and then he's going to
punt for into space although like I
wonder if Thor's Superman's weak against
magic so I wonder if I'm yeah I'm
getting oh no I'm getting in my own head
oh it's fun to go down the rabbit hole
with this stuff oh dude I've been doing
it since I was you know I used to work
at a comic book store and I'd be in the
back just it's so funny because people
online a lot of people like will say
stuff like you know like you do
and you do that and you have a loud
opinion and I'm just the same 14 year
old kid in the back of a comic store
going listen Walter aim could
technically be Batman in a fight because
there's no way for Batman Matt Murray
never lose that magic max landis you've
been generous with your time you're
welcome here any time thanks for coming
by buddy my absolute pleasure thank you
so much
absolutely so what is the dream sequel
you'd like to see give us your pitch in
the comments section below if you have
the best dream sequel pitch for the
movie of your choice we're gonna send
you a screen junkies t-shirt once again
thanks to max landis I'm Hal Rudnick hit
me up on Twitter by bike to me the
problem with Avengers old age of Ultron
and with almost every other big movie we
saw this year is it always ends the same
with them saying we're going to destroy
the world in the next 20 minutes and
less and you're never going to destroy
the world so who cares